welcome back to 8701
so again we have now all tools in place
to do a next round of cross-section
calculations
we have seen how to set up a matrix
element we have seen how to build
spin averaged or to treat the spin and
then specifically
to calculate spin averaged amplitudes
uh using cardiomyostic all right
i'm not saying that this is all easy now
um but
you have seen all necessarily elements
to calculate a cross section for
qrd process so let's summarize
so we have seen that we can set up the
matrix element
using final primary rules for qd we have
seen
how to set up the spin average
matrix element squared using the traces
now we would have to evaluate the traces
in order to drive
this formula here so i spare you a
precise discussion of this step here
but you can actually follow this quite
straightforwardly
let me just step back a little bit
before we proceed my goal for the class
is not to have you calculate all kinds
of
cross-section processes but to
understand how you would do it
um for the purpose of really
understanding where dependencies come
from
and where this kind of calculation has
its limitations
the first part is you want to need see
you know what are the dependencies on
the number on the cotton the couplings
involved
you know you see this g square for
example that's a rather important effect
we also want to see so fermi's golden
rule how we get actually then to the
cross section from the
matrix element calculation so if you
ever had to calculate a matrix element
i'm
going to ask you to do this once maybe
twice
as part of the homework set um i
encourage you to open a book
follow the rules look up tricks
how to work with traces and then you
should get to a reasonable solution in a
reasonable amount of time
but here for for the purpose of this
discussion we want to just have a look
at a few specific cases
where we make assumptions and
simplifications to the discussion
so the first one is called mod
scattering
so here again we are at this example of
a spin half particle scattering with a
spin half particle
different spin half particle so the
exchange of a photon
so we used the example of an electron
muon scattering
but this muon here could also be a
proton or any other nuclei
with spin half the assumption for scots
from what scattering we're using is that
the mass
of this particle the muon is much
heavier than the mass of the electron
and you know it's true that the muon is
200 times heavier than an electron a
proton is even heavier
any heavier nuclei obviously is even
heavier than this
in mod scattering we also make the
assumption that the momentum involved
are lower than the mass of the heavy
particle and that the
recoil of the heavy nuclei or the neuron
can be neglected
if we do that we can write then write
the um
differential cross section using
firmness golden rule as a spin
average matrix element squared divided
by two pi
m squared okay if you then use this
kinematic information
right you basically start from this
matrix element here
and then you use those vectors those
four vectors for your momentum of the
first second
third and fourth particle you find that
many of the factors are simplifying to
me so p2 times p3 is me and so are many
of the others
and there's a few important factors for
example
p1 minus p3 square is minus 4p square
sine square theta half
and similarly p1 times p3
so you put this all in you know again
starting from this very
formula we just had discussed before
and you put all the simplifications and
you get this matrix element
which already that look that looks much
more manageable right there's an m
square there's a p
square there's a cosine square theta
half term and some factor which depends
on the momentum and the mass
okay and if you then add this to fermi's
golden rule you find
this equation for your mod scattering
again this is the scattering
of two spin half different spin half
particles where one is much heavier
the outgoing momentum are small and the
recoil of the heavier particles can be
neglected
so this mods formula describes for
example the coulomb scattering
so the scattering this photon on the
electric charge
of a nuclei and the scattering particle
is not
too heavy and not too energetic like an
electron
we also assume that everything involved
here is point like we haven't
had any discussion on on the
charge distribution of the nuclei or
anything we assume that this is a point
like particle
okay we can further discuss now the case
where the initial state particles are
non-relativistic
so here our momentum formulas simplify
this is simply
m square p square is 2 m e
and alpha is q 1 times
q 2. those are the electric charges
and so then our differential cross
section further simplifies to something
you have already seen
the differential cross section is equal
to q1
times q2 divided by 4 times the energy
sine square theta half squared and we
have seen that
as already the the rather fault
scattering cross section when we
discuss cross-section measurements in a
geometrical kind of sense
so this kind of closes closes the loop
here in our cross-sectional discussion
and how we can think about
those things the rutherford
cross-section is nothing else but
a big billiard ball being hit by a small
billiard wall
and looking at how the the cross-section
actually how the or the cross section
differentially kind of evolves out of
this
out of the setup all right
um in this sequence we have a little bit
more of a discussion
what happens now if we introduce higher
order terms
and how can we think about those
solutions
and then i have two extra lectures where
we go back
and discuss spin and also how we can
actually understand this in the
lagrangian setup
you